الأعراض متشابهة، لذلك إذا
مرض طفلك، فقد يكون من الصعب معرفة
ما إذا كان مصابًا بفيروس كورونا المستجد (كوفيد-19)، أو الأنفلونزا RSV أو
تكلفة نزلات البرد مقابل أموال الازدحام، فهذه
أعراض شائعة لجميع هذه
الفيروسات الأربعة. الدكتور آندي شين من مركز
رعاية صحة الأطفال في أتلانتا  يقول إن هناك
طرقًا للمساعدة في التمييز بين
الأمراض، انظر أولاً إلى مدى سرعة
ظهور الأعراض، حيث يكون الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي (RSV) والبوفيد (Povid) أكثر
تدرجًا عادةً في بداية الأعراض
وقد يبدأان بسيلان في الأنف ثم
يتطوران إلى أعراض أخرى، في حين أن فيروس
كورونا (كوفيد-19) هو الفيروس الحالي لفيروس كورونا.  القلق
بشأن ما يقرب من 19 ألف
حالة دخول إلى المستشفى في الأسبوع الماضي، بدأت مستويات RSV في
الارتفاع في الجنوب مع
زيادات طفيفة في غرب ووسط
البلاد. فقدان الشهية هو
شيء كلاسيكي نربطه
مع RSV ولكن بالطبع الكثير من
الشهية المرتبطة به  الكثير من
الالتهابات الأخرى بالإضافة إلى أعراض الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي
قد تشمل أيضًا السعال والعطس والحمى والصفير ونزلات
البرد عادةً ما تصل إلى ذروتها خلال
يومين إلى ثلاثة أيام مع السعال والتهاب الحلق
وسيلان أو انسداد الأنف والعينين المائيتين
والعطس. قد تشمل أعراض كوفيد-19 أعراض
السعال ونوبات قصيرة من الحمى
وضيق في التنفس  التنفس وآلام البطن والتعب
وأعراض الأنفلونزا قد تشمل الحمى والقشعريرة والصداع وسيلان
الأنف
والغثيان والتعب إذا كان أحد الوالدين قلقًا
بشأن الطفل، فهذا عادة ما
يكون مؤشرًا على الحاجة إلى رعاية إضافية من أجل الصحة. أنا ماندي
غايثر